Le plus grand festival de musique d'Écosse avec
une performance exclusive de notre part en
tête des classements qu'ils font d'accord, alors vous êtes whoo hé sale Pink pourquoi ne pouvez-
vous pas simplement vous appeler les vagins oh
vous savez ce qu'ils vont faire qu'est-ce que
vous faites j'ai  c'est pour m'exploser la vaisselle
blague nous avons besoin d'un outil de force industrielle
plus difficile pense que j'ai trouvé rah
Oh comédien oh t'as pissé sur toi-même va
te faire [ __ ] mec
salut je roule qui est-ce que c'est cet
inconnu Duke elle est incroyablement affreuse
mademoiselle Gillis bébé  attendez ce que nous devons
bien jouer ou nous sommes tous invités à revenir
livraison de Bobby
oh n'en faites pas une grosse soirée nous avons un
concert demain d'accord nous en ferons un
plan un
avez-vous déjà vu Dumbo sur des champignons
ma main vient  retour personne n'est merci
Roi les choses sont horribles en ce moment